[Musique]
il vous reviendra en tant qu'observateur
d'exercer votre droit des garçons du
processus électoral en cours de l'humour
tout vient volume à des suggestions à
travers l apport de l'observation a fait
d'une telle lettre
les hausser la qualité de nos
prestations ou voir des menus
comportement l'organisation et la
supervision des opérations électorales
ont toujours constitué une activité très
délicate
l'anneau concret dans la mesure où la
préservation de la belgique allait
souvent publicitaires
les membres de la ceni éléments 17
aimablement plus observant les éditions
harlequin avant leur entrée raconter
encore et toujours qui jure on pariera
chercheurs il a gelé jupe
[Musique]
quelle heure de jeu
mais belgrade
dont on a ces deux fois oui personne
j'ai changé depuis la naissance
deux personnes
[Musique]
les dix athlètes ça c'est moi
le problème là aide les gens c'est une
zone où il ya même pas d'électricité
n'en parlons pas d'avoir une photocopie
d'un joli est venue de cloud août 2009
contre les invités de ce genre pour la
série v les jeunes trop faible
photocopies ils sont partis je vous
écoute jusque là les intérêts eh bien ce
ne seront pas du tout le taux de
participation par tous est faible parce
que les gens n'ont pas les pistes donc à
l'absence le non-respect de jour et par
les agents des centres des bureaux que
j'ai visités il n'y a pas d'argent des
censeurs général heures mais là j'aime
sanctionner chara
il ya en a vu et vire policier à la
retraite qui est agent recenseur
ils ne voient même pas reculer les
numéros là je suis un ivg crise oblige
sont les perdants semble vraiment
je songe à l'essentiel rien vrai de
réussite qui je disais il ya plein on a
rencontré ce n'est pas ça l'écriture les
surcharges et à d'autres qui s'amusent à
paris on dirait que c'est la couleur il
veut
on aurait dû tout dans les registres aux
malades du tout
par rapport à tout ce qui est entrepris
pour favoriser la participation ou pour
rendre le processus le scrutin plus
transparent ou plus sincères ses traits
ce que vous avez des attentes
particulières par rapport à l'aspect
civil toutes les insuffisances que l'on
peut constater dans le fonctionnement
d'une démembrements dans le
fonctionnement des bleus du roi a fait
c'est imputable aux usa le président de
la ceni les mêmes de la ceni n'ont pas
désiré démembrement de l'asim qui sont
leurs collaborateurs nous n'avons pas de
moyens de coercition contre nos propres
démons ça c'est une faiblesse même du
mal mais c'est le terrain
nous avons effectivement constaté que
c'est pas parce que les gens ne
voulaient pas sortir
mais c'est là l'organisation qui a
failli ou pour la commune de la mairie
de boulmiougou
il y avait 48 bureaux s'est dit dans un
rayon de moins de 3 2 des kilomètres
c'est ça qui fait que au niveau de
ouagadougou nous n'avons eu que 440 et
csc 440 inscrits
[Musique]
jusqu'à ce jour c'était à moins de
quatre mois
la tenue des élections nous n'avons pas
de fichier complet la mode que l'on
pourra voter avec la carte d'identité du
passeport ou la carte militaire
c'est dire que et on ne peut pas avoir
su dreyfus déjà qu'ils n'ont pas le
droit du mois dernier
on ne retiendra que ceux qui sont pros
c'est celle des trois pièces et donc qui
comporte de redoubler pour obtenir cela
nous avons prévu de croiser nos
informations avec celles de nomi
ministre des affaires étrangères pour
mieux les tenues que ceux qui sont donc
ces trois pièces qu'autorisé pour je
pense que d'ici demain après demain le
fichier électoral brut va être prêt et
le fichier lectra est plus discrète tous
ceux qui se sont inscrits selon la loi
avec la lagune et sans plaque d'identité
passeport ou la carte militaire
il faut comprendre c'est pour le moins
[Musique]
il enverra comme sa compagne de l'eau de
roche qu'il a continué m contre nous
l'an dans une colline la ressent pour un
ami p dame ait eu lieu et le sud donc
les blocages sur les ans la même commune
et dans la commune il ya 64 bureaux de
vote dont vous trouvez dans les deux
continents la 62e de wade la commune de
couflens chaque électeur on a une fiche
comme ça donc un électeur il a un
formulaire pour côtier
ce qui allait d'ailleurs dû s'arrêter
dans cette vidéo c'est le numéro deux de
ces chiffres maintenant comme il est
assez on s'est dit que il peut y avoir
des yeux la personne privée avec des
fleurs non on dit le coin le numéro le
17 si vous l'avez de prendre aussi denis
de le laisser comme ça en détention ne
trouve pas la personne avec le niveau de
la pièce qu'on ne retrouve avec pour
l'essai de lui lécher avec les numéros
de cirque mais à bloc qui se sont
contentés seulement de les pointer le
bout de ses idées
[Musique]
maintenant on se retrouve avec un
village avec trois bébés rats le 3 mai
le troisième bébé est là c'est une le
japon à faire pour savoir quel est le
pont d oeil d'utiliser des sens noble
puisque samedi qu'au deuxième naissance
aux ménages les plus vertueux il ya un
qui doit aller avec de vrais bébés vins
nappe mais à un tu peux aller avec un
autre bleu le vôtre c'est une leurs
demandes et en repli de mettre le nom du
village
enfin c'est le chef donc il a fauté ni
avril apporter encore un numéro de nom
de la commune et ça devient comme si
c'était le chef de l'hôtel
village maintenant nous on a retrouvé un
visage de ceux qui à l église pour le
défi donc on s'est dit que seulement 1
des bureaux de vote la joie aller avec
ce deuxième de ghislain mais lequel plus
que tout c'est warner
on a insisté pour que les agents et
fonceur la prime toujours de la daps de
l'étape et les numéros de la pièce et la
date d'établissement label
d'établissement de la pièce doit être
inscrit intégralement au complet
maintenant par exemple on à l'année
seulement les amplis l'année ils n'ont
pas pris la dass
non quand on n'a pas la date complexe
difficile de les trouver la pièce
[Musique]
je
oubli
[Musique]
vous savez que diop et évoluent et les
coûts la même
juste parce que google
et nous avons rencontré et le petit rôle
au service où les séries mania
et là
d'essence il y avait le passeport la
carte militaire et lui avaient également
dans quatre militants auront trouvé une
occupation sur la carte d'identité ou le
passeport ne contiennent pas pour
le savoir la filiation nous ne sommes
pas chargés de faire répéter et en
disant que les gens s'expriment avec la
technique et du passeport dans un
chantier géré pendant une bonne claque
humiliation l adjectif autre nouveauté
une situation est aujourd'hui conduit
une liste électorale sans la filiation
et produit également une carte
électorale sans l'association
de mon point de vue c'est une carte est
en principe nul et de nul effet pour les
gares dont des destructions des slatina
vigueur alors moi je propose dans ces
conditions que la commission attend que
nous venons en à peine une décision qui
permet à la ceni de courant produit des
dix électorales et des cartes
électorales sur la base des clairons je
ne sais pas d'une ambulance avant par le
mercure
sur le terrain les cap au lycée on va
attendre aussi que le gouvernement
prenait un texte avant le premier
sainte-catherine sur la marelle délai
beaucoup plus novices nous allons
continuer à tirer nos craintes
nous espérons que nos gouvernants d'ici
là puisqu'ils connaissent contre un
petit battement de son texte qui va nous
permettre de combler afin de donner
corps
pour les gens qui sont inscrits sur une
liste le jour du scrutin on leur dit
vous n'allez pas vous allez passer la
compilation pour une origine
si nous permettons aux personnes qui
souhaitent des sumos liste viennent avec
leurs 90 pour voter nos soldats et on
s'assure qu'ils ont l'art de voter qui
sont inscrits sur la liste et quelles
sont les pièces
est-ce qu'on violent l'expression bien
connu c'est le cadre législatif
l'expression bien connu ce n'est pas le
carcan législatif un câble
c'est une délimitation dans laquelle on
se mouille un carcan pour ceux qui sort
ce quelqu'un cas quand on vous le met au
pied vous êtes bloqués aux états il
parce que vous êtes un fou dangereux
nouveau bloqué par la loi ce n'est pas
ça qu'il faut se référer calme à
montesquieu aussi l'esprit des lois
la lettre des lois oui mais l'esprit des
lois
aussi est-ce qu'on nous faire le con
nous fait dire le droit
je disais partager sa portée à propos du
code civil par le bras mais au delà de
droit alors moi je ne pense pas que ce
soit nécessaire qu on s'autocensure d
ici on a des difficultés
les rois se contredisent les
dispositions des gars se contredisent
il faut avancer la solution
n'en déplaise à ceux qui prétendent le
contraire qui s occupe de poser le
moindre problème
le moins de tours sociaux c'est celle
qu'on a arrêté on a dit aux gens venez
vous inscrire vos long terme avec sa axa
les gens sont venus s'inscrire
volontairement maintenant ceux qui sont
venus aux mains avec leurs séries b même
avec
un trouillard et faire la filiation
fondeur on ne leur a pas demandé la
plupart de ces gens là les trois quarts
sont illettrés en ils sont venus se
présenter une pièce mais nous on sait
que la loi ne nous obligez pas à demain
à de nouvelles affiliations et on n'a
pas fait et maintenant aux diverses
options
il se présente au bureau de vote on
garde nos noms ya patafil d'argent mais
dire à ben vous m'avez demandé de
produire une série b j'ai produit m'a
séduit probable n'a pas plus la vie des
gens c'est ça quand même deux tours plus
tôt par la seconde et yappa d'affilée à
chambre c'est pas grave
cap chat avant tu as ta carte d'identité
et jack a même un tac au tac à des
lectures autres maintenant comme on l'a
dit le gouvernement prendra ses
responsabilités
la liste électorale est celle que nous
avons confectionné à partir des
discussions nous allons tirer les cartes
d'électeur ou tout le monde maintenant
celui qui mérite un rôle de ce ne sera
pas la faute de la csn
[Musique]
il
et nenê nous avons roulé à travers trois
mois emprunter la route technique qui
moi de recevoir n'a pas produit les
effets escomptés alors nourrir les cas
les juges pour agir dans les limites du
raisonnable
ainsi la ceni bourdillas des cartes
d'électeurs tous ceux qui sont inscrits
sur les listes électorales
au total 3 millions d euros
4800 ces deux personnes figuraient les
fichiers ils sont répartis dans tous les
six ans tracy qui vaut des profs nous
allons exploser les difficultés que nous
avons eues a mené l'opération de
croisement à nous avons fait donc que
les rapprochements des bases de données
nous avons rencontré des difficultés des
trois autres il y à des personnes qui
ont en plus d'établir leur carte
nationale d'identité avec les
certificats de nationalité et vous savez
que cette pièce n'était pas admise pour
s'inscrire sur une liste électorale donc
dans l'opération on allait les trouvez
pas et il y as v d'une simple et cent
mille personnes
nous avons eu nos vergers pas finir lieu
est également et les militaires il ya
près de 6000 militaires qui sont
inscrits sur nos listes avec leur carte
militaire s'est retournée par la loi
même l'onu ne dispose pas d'un fichier
et de quatre militaires
donc on ne peut pas posséder au
croisement avec la quartier de tel et
puis il y a aussi le goût ni dans son
travail n'a pas pris le soin de mettre
et
date d'établissement des actes de
naissance jugements supplétifs et c'est
la force mais nous nous sommes retrouvés
avec des plusieurs personnes arrêtent le
menu des pièces si bien que ainsi
devenir l'opération nous allions laissé
de côté et des personnes qui sont en
règle vis-à-vis de la loi mais qui ne
serait pas retenu et c'est là c'était
des centaines de milliers de personnes
nous pensons qu'il n'a pas le droit de
tuer est déjà qu'ils sont allés
vis-à-vis de la loi du toit du monde
monsieur pénale des personnes voire d un
directeur d'école nantes et caen se
réunira pas de fraude
non et si vous avez une femme de
lecteurs et où n'a pas de captivité vous
pouvez pas voter dans
de cela
[Musique]
on voit qu'elle est guérie à la ceni que
c'est qu'un tirage au sort pour déterrer
les candidats seront disposées sur des
techniques
il s'agira de chacun des maires nous
sommes des hommes est venu tirer sur
deux dimensions
j'ai passé
[Musique]
ça fait 5
séoul a bonjour 6 4 8 6 fois le 3 mars
quand le dit non c'est le premier à
l'elysée price à voir et puis les
[Musique]
allemands n'avaient plus de voix que
certains camps principaux indices
actions
le gars est celle qui se livre qui
s'adresse à des photos je vais vous
ville a beaucoup des gens n'est point de
vue il ya un pas que le royaume qui est
conservé dans les vidéos la seconde
tentative
mais j'étais petit pipi caca une image
non c'est pire bush
ok donc je peux si y'a pas le feu
la couleur n'est pas la même que ça et
quant au fond c'est quand même avec des
gars dit quand vous voyez il faudra être
atteints de myopie ou des façons en
compte la différence entre cette couleur
et cette couleur et le font ici quand
même qui est assez assez foncée espace
donc ce que vous voulez c'est c'est eh
bien si et je pense que quand on est
déjà là ya beaucoup de pixels
c'est passé comme cela la place de
prison donc je suis vigilant et lucide
je n'ai pas peur c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas l'excellence voilà c'est ça
aussi
six années de crise et pour d'autres
c'est un fait bon usage
c'est peu mais bon je sais déjà que je
sache qu'il est privé voilà j y vois pas
ce que moi je vais passer quelque chose
qui n'est pas dépasser ses objectifs ce
qui correspond déjà ce qui ravit je
n'aime pas vraiment
donc le passionnant jusqu'au julien que
terminé la semaine passée oblige elle
devient une photo au consensus était à
la fois qu'ils viennent avec cette photo
tonnes parce que c'est ça à faire de
l'autre les feux en avant une photo
qu'est-ce qu'on va les autres la fusion
et vous dit non
en face de la mairie nous aide on la
renvoie les valses et le peloton je te
fout le coup d envoi les fautes et les
probables des fauteurs de produire des
faux de l'épreuve dont ici que le rien
avant des photos de pièces d'identité
même lancer nous l'acceptons cette façon
mais par les rebondissements il ya
défaut de l'épreuve organisée qui n'ont
rien à vendre des photos que dans une
petite ajouté c'est de voir une foule en
soit c'est constitutionnel a accepté
d'une photo de propagande non nous le
plus large et le voleur de 10 on a le
droit de changer une photo qui est vue
du croisé continue vous n'êtes pas seuls
les zones à bas allemagne a beau clamer
qu une autre photo nous avons pour lui
refuser
pas de changement non on le produire est
identiquement votre photo moi j'avais
projet d'améliorer les images des gens
mais si ça devient pour le nouveau le
produit qu est ce qu est ce que vous
avez donné aux conséquences sur terre
battue les a transférés
[Musique]
oublié ses origines germain tient à la
ceni intérim de ce qu'ils mangent et
cécile moreau est de créer la confiance
et de l'entretenir entre les différentes
saveurs en fait certainement pas le sac
et au sahara qui briguent ce n'est pas
parce qu il n ya pas de formules this
vous devez tirer tout le monde
l'intérêt n'était pas très politique
l'intérêt de ce nom avec l'opposition de
la société civile ouverte par la
majorité la devine qu'il était tout le
monde le même pied d'égalité
chargé le choix nous prépare l'opération
devait tracer
il faut l'aborder vous vous soyez
vraiment c'est dans le travail pour
récupérer les cas il faut que la
personne ce cheval est bien physiquement
que vous assurer de l'identité de la
personne et maintenant vous avez une
demande est justement l'une des passes
et qui disent comme nous le montre sa
carte d'électeur
vous récupérez peut-être renseignez vous
vient ce manque d'essence qui son
passeport et vous vérifiez sur la liste
que vous aviez si effectivement il est
régulièrement inscrits alors je voulais
trouver maintenant à 4 me mettais un
rêve gentillesse pour lui dit merci
[Musique]
les sculpteurs qui peut croire votre
aise ici 95% de ceux qui sont inscrits
les soirées très las des naissances est
ce que les gens savent qu'ils ne
bouclent pas vous révéler sensibles mais
sa hausse à 0,5 seulement valse
difficulté majeure celle des retraites
elle est illettrée prennent ce type ont
pas vu que la campagne qui a démarré
aussi c'est que
mais actuellement se met en place voilà
bon il ya quelques difficultés mais bon
ça c'est ce qu'on retient l'erreur est
humaine
c'est notamment les quatre éléments il
ya beaucoup d'erreurs à moi parce
qu'issus de sexe féminin maintenant
mieux vaut ce n'est là qu'à deviennent
vidéo il aime le sexe féminin décerné
aux états unis qui nous a transformés
rallye raid dont beaucoup de doigté dire
qu'on a trouvé un abo on a beaucoup
on a aussi le silence iccat qui ne porte
pas de nom et prénom et les électeurs
voient là bas n'est pas bien en tant que
tel puisque derrière elles allez manger
à la nation l'âge notamment
mais le nom et le prénom qui s'apparent
thiam certains il est dénué là dessus
via des numéros
voilà donc ça la fait partie des avec la
mention mais risqué le numéro le tout
aussi la liste web les socialistes les
niveaux socialisation c'est un massage
sarko n'est ce pas déjà
la terre
[Musique]
attendez j'ai une prise avec
les deux
[Musique]
il
ap ap le petit problème
vous arrivez à trouver facilement
l'horreur
voyez on devrait aussi enjoint demande à
l'arrivée par exemple des cartes vierges
nous il n'y a pas de calcul s'il vous
plaît monsieur qu'une phase peut être
vierge mais la casse tête faites contre
moi parce que les absents est venue de
l'économie appelle de narnia le nom de
l'assassin parce qu il ya d autres il
informe ça n'arrive quand ça il ya
maintenant j'aime pas le prénom nom
c'est ben ali ça me sert elle est
vraiment et c'est une tâche et vous
laisser on n'a pas vu la confiance du
président à qui la tutelle à des coudes
aux cartes
moi même je suis moi je te le dis
souvent amené moi j'adore la diffusion
de spectacles qui avait quitté l'objet
d' erreur et dans la mise de côté et on
peut pas l'être et rennes avant tout il
faut quand même les déconcerter les
mains du côté j'aime est à l'appui son
devenir le masque des situations nous
avons énuméré quatre là j'y joue durant
24 heures sur 24
les machines ne sont pas été une seule
fois donc il s'est dit c'est quelquefois
des élèves de ce1 mais nous avons déjà
inscrits dans des moments de
la beauté pour combler tous leurs
craintes et si on garde ça ces quelques
king pour le corps ou c'est parce que
nous allons la liste de ceux qui ont des
pièces autorisé à la loi pour voter que
nous pouvons de la pyrrhus enficher
genève
mais ce n'est pas le knock de croisement
qui chante pas du tout c'est plutôt un
voyage qui chantent
en effet la loi n'a pas prévu une
cloison comme vous l'avez la loi la
vente de décor à la russie dans ses
roues même qu'un de clients c'est avec
une certaine théorie pour dire autant
qu'il faut laisser les gens à s'inscrire
avec les actes de naissance après le
court à une certaine théorie de la
modification de la loi qui termine c'est
celui avec la naissance c'est une course
de loi 2
c'était un projet de ron du gouvernement
un peu dire que le gouvernement a
consulté la ceni peut être avant de le
président de l'occasion le signer nous
avons rencontré des partis d'opposition
pour dire que voilà
l'introduction de nos lits dans la
confection de la vie n'est pas avec les
interventions ceni de l'article
d'attention ou unique et c'est nous qui
devons concevoir la liste la gérer et la
prochaine en son temps vous avez que ce
nous échappent et prend de friches ap
nous n'aurons aucun loyer à un moment
donné d'interview
nous apprécions ce qui est de faire
ensemble pour colliger signe à corriger
tous les efforts que nous sommes loin du
consensus de plus haut rang à égalité
deux mois les lecteurs
on dit est à placer dans les micro
mesures
le lutin vous ont décidé une fois ci est
ce que les isoloirs sont disposés de
telle sorte que effectivement les
électeurs n'ont pas l'impression qu'il a
les yeux qui la lie à le dérider les
candidats doses sauf signifie tout
commentaire
dans la salle il en va de même des
membres de groupes de gauche mais il se
trouve que dans une localité qui peut
nous raconter dans le cinq
il était un nom du bureau de vote et il
est à présent de gros de vote et il y
avait un des leviers d'un candidat qui
chaque fois que quelqu'un autre issue en
fait il ya un mot qu'il prononce
il nous raconte comment lui valent une
sorte de mot de passe
me convainc pas là
après ça devient suspect danse et
répétitif et tout ça il sera c'est 5
euros
ça vous dit là bas donc il faut voir un
symbole c'est qu'ils sont capables de
faire le travail sans aucune
appartenance politique on me l'a dit
sinon dans cette collaboration ne faut
pas que les gens pensent que non je suis
membre je peux attendre place
c'est ce sont des militants de mon parti
que je vais envoyer là aussi ces listes
vous savez bien au travail est sous
contrôle du conseil constitution qui a
mené par exemple l'exposition des natifs
passé il ya des centaines de bureaux
dont le but était annulé parce que les
stimuler les rendez-vous de vote ont été
au dessus de la loi a prévu
combien
très bien
s et abc départ ça s'est resserré
finalement nous votre travail aussi des
points la paix sociale si vous faites
moi votre travail
ici la paix sociale valletoux bleus
nous avons les isoloirs zoom et les
vaincre rigide indélébile et l'impôt de
forme les cachets pour estime que les
cats électeurs et ainsi de suite les
lampes etc
[Musique]
debout tient à penser qu'ils mieux que
certains mais comme je vous ai dit tu le
vois des temps libres
peut-être que l'offre politique n'est
pas simple à tout va il ya quand même
une seule personne sur ecolo suis un
observateur du tracé des actions pour le
cynisme et la démocratie bon mon
inquiétude est de savoir vraiment si les
cartes électorales sont vraiment fiable
au cours de votre vous agissiez que
l'écart était présent dans la tablette
heures et avoir de document
alors est-ce que vous n'êtes rassure que
la carte de l'état lui avait délivré à
la population elle vient d'un électeur
et vient de 570 personnes nanties d'un
seul jour que quelqu'un la faculté pour
la fortifier les la fonction de la carte
d'électeur cdm d'ikea les recteurs ont
il doit aller voter toutefois à la team
de 500
il est dit que le jour du vote pour le
prouver
présenté comme pièce d'identification et
la carte nationale d'identité le
passeport ou la carte militaire et
pièces qui présente des photographies de
façon à ce que les membres du bureau de
vote mais un et deux c'est la personne
qui se présente pour lui et c'est dire
que si vous elle respire avec la
renaissance parce que vous n'aviez pas
voir les acteurs nationale d'identité
vous êtes obligé les tout faire pour
l'avoir avant le jour du site
sinon vous voulez maintenant et le
gouvernement à mener des actions aux
fesses de l'oni et pour que comme des
livres et plus rapidement les cartes
nationales d'identité et j'écoutais il y
a deux jours
me et qui dans une complainte ps qui
disait que il avait délivré 4 millions
de cartes nationales d'identité j'espère
que les dans les 4 millions il y as
notoire souligne le maire
à l'heure actuelle au 21ème siècle nous
pouvons pas voter vraiment à l'aide d'un
bien si tous je vous ai entendu dire
tout de suite que la tâche est fiable
quand je parle pas de la région du nord
où nous pouvons nous retrouver avec
prennent du temps à cannes à année
oui madame et on verra demain pour aller
voter
paris n'a pas d'obligation c'est sûr
dont la liste électorale vous avez en
annuel exemple vous voulez les poulets
voix
il ya bien sûr tellement et le prénom de
la personne son année de naissance
la pièce qui a servi un esprit les
résulats de l'artiste
la date d'émission du laxisme même si
vous êtes des homonymes ne peut pas
avoir tous ses aînés mada est d'un type
ce n'est pas possible c'est enfin
l'actualité un dangereux de se rendre à
calais prestation sur
la carte d'électeur tracteur ou non
parfois peut-être personne vous pouvez
dire un mot depuis quelques jours des
représentants du candidat et sont venus
une fois d'avoir été informé et ensuite
ils ont tenu des conférences du pech et
ils ont donc posé un certain nombre de
problèmes notamment en ce qui concerne
le contenu de la carte d'électeur
nous avons simplement dit que ce procès
tout nous sommes des alliés ne peuvent
être changées effet si ils ont vraiment
des cuivres sérieux prendre la carte
d'électeur nous sommes en démocratie et
qu'ils ont tout le loisir de suffisament
de dumas les tribunaux nous sommes prêts
à aller
ému
[Musique]
nous réclame 6
je ne vais pas
cette baisse est de 12
[Musique]
etc
je
[Musique]
on met le doigt merci visible à manama
la pérennité non le territoire
[Musique]
[Rires]
et
toulouse 2e n'a pas de difficultés par
rapport à ceux qui n'ont pas l'air non
vous avez donné réponse est oui il est
conscient et aux douleurs c'est qu'en
bas le mans et qui ont l'âme en scylla
plus initial conçu
voici le nom figure la bassée aura
personne à sa crainte a mais on leur
avait dit que ses fils ne leur matériel
voire faut alors ajouter le nom quand le
soleil noté toutes les coordonnées ce
serait faire voter la preuve voilà le
nancéien roger mahmoud
on a vécu mon menu toutes les
coordonnées sont les même temps l'âge et
lui-même les nombres c'est seulement
voilà yao bo cessa de jeu léger et la
all et des mini l'aider maimouna êtres
humains c'est désiré matériel
on ne peut pas faire porter aux citoyens
s'est donnée la fin de l'année c'est ce
cri se donner la peine dans les faits ça
c'est inhibé et à produire un matériel
qui est qu'on peut établir
parce que par comparaison celle de
ressort clairement on ne peut pas
empêcher les gens de votre femme
même la loi dit que jusqu'au jour du
vote
on peut causer désiré materi même dans
la loi c'est simple
sept points c'est à nous de payer et les
hommes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maxime kaboré
la sq ont pas
voir
[Musique]
il
quoi
m
alors les primes à la formation des
premières et ça se déroule bien nous
avons treize équipes correspondant 13
les gens à chaque équipe où nous avons
en statique il me donne un total de 104
ans
là
[Musique]
nous sommes tenus par l'état on a des
délais il faut tenir donc nous allons
sûrement continuer à mettre la pression
ces jeunes gens font que même cuisse le
soir nous nous sommes donnés les
résultats
[Musique]
m